[Music]
hello everybody my name is Pete Holmes
and welcome to the conan after our
stand-up series presented by Pepsi NEXT
where we get to showcase some of the
show's favorite comedians
tonight's performer plays gene on NBC's
up all night and this month he releases
his second full-length comedy album
please welcome everybody our good friend
Matt Braunger thank you thanks very much
Oh a lot of movies coming out this this
summer good times and I don't know I I
have a t-shirt for the movie the harder
they come which is a Jimmy Cliff film
and a great soundtrack and only bring it
up because the star of the movie
sang the theme song from the movie he
sang his own theme song like nobody does
that anymore like yeah like Will Smith
but he's rapping I want to see a star
that kroons his own theme song right
like just once I'd like to see ladies
and gentlemen singing the theme song
with hit movie Inception
please welcome Leonardo DiCaprio he
comes out Inception it's a dream inside
dream inside a dream inside dream inside
a dream inside a dream inside a dream
inside a dream it's a dream inside a
dream inside a dream and just goes on
like that the whole song dream inside a
dream we must go deeper that's the name
I'm not a big fan of catchphrases for
comedians when a comet comes out and
does a joke it is like ham and eggs and
the crowds like ham and eggs and I'm
like where's the joke but I love it when
regular folks have like catchphrases
like there's an Italian restaurant in my
neighborhood which first off is so
Italian it's got the checkered
tablecloths the garlic hanging from the
ceiling the bottles of Chianti on a
table like the name of the restaurant
should literally just be that song
apostrophe s should be the name of the
restaurant right and the guy that sheets
you has the best catchphrase ever like
first off he looks like Super Mario if
you like bought a condo he like just got
the mustache he's back to like jump and
punch nothing in a coin
out of the air and when he seats you he
gets the menus and by the way I go to
this restaurant to hear this catchphrase
it makes my whole week he gets amazing
guys tape off afar right this way and he
walked got like a jaunty walk and he
said something menus goes okay guys it's
spaghetti theme and walks away
yeah that's forget eat I'm Mario and
beaten up anyone says it's not spaghetti
time right now say that as you drift off
to sleep you will have marvelous dreams
tonight he's spaghetti thank you could
give me the worst news of my life for
that accident I'd be at least a little
bit cool with it
do you have the test results actor Mario
yes you got it the syphilis I do
all right you're adorable your body
won't be being around place huh I did
dr. Mario had to cut down on drinking
recently not for my health just to
improve my hangovers yes it's weird like
there's so much out of you notices they
get so much worse once you hit 30 like
in your 20s your hangovers are almost
fun you know you're like hey there's
hangar frogs in my stomach my brains on
fire all right what are we doing tonight
it's a good time right and your 30s
hangovers are like I'm gonna have a
stroke I think my arms are numb my brain
is honest and cool like in your 20s you
make plans for your hangovers you're
like I'm not doing anything today except
eating a family-sized bag of ruffles and
watching all the Rocky movies that's it
screw you guys that's my party all right
all right and your 30s you're like I
guess I'll go to the food court at the
mall so someone might catch me when I
have the inevitable stroke that's
happening at 4:00 p.m. exactly on the
dot hopefully died with some Panda
Express in my stomach we'll see like
here's the thing about hangovers you
have to order food that kills your body
to heal your hangover that is some
horrific irony food with it's bad for
you to heal your hangover and I would
just get so messed up I want or the kind
of food that doesn't exist like a baby
goes leather later but it wants a pickle
like that kind of thing
like the way to come over and I'd be
like just uh-huh give me aa
just uh just give me up a plate of
cheese baby isn't a hot boy whatever
that is I don't know what it is just
make it I don't know I'm in such pain
and some ham dancers whatever those are
just make them like just once I want the
waiter know exactly what I'm talking
about like let me get a plate of cheese
babies yeah you want a gang or a tribe a
tribe and uh hey
and give me some some ham dancers how
many uh Narmada an armada and a hot boy
what a nice mood to be like angry no
melancholy melancholy hot boy and hurry
please I don't know why there isn't a
hangover Airlines honestly to like how
many times have you gone home from
vacation hungover every single time
pretty much there should be a like you
pay 50 bucks extra for an exit row
hundred bucks extra you fly hangover
Airlines like you get on you get five
advil in a box of cheez-its just for you
you sit down you open the armrest is a
tube unlimited Gatorade suck away right
all you want hangover Airlines everybody
shot your frickin mouth be quiet on
hangover Airlines do not talk to me I am
so sick of being on a flight at 7:00
a.m. next to someone I just said coffee
you wanna see a picture of my niece hmm
I am sweating bourbon shut up I'll leave
you guys with this I I used to live in
Chicago which if you've never been gets
God doesn't love you anymore cold in the
winter and there's four months of
sunshine a year and people are at least
half drunk the whole time and one way
they stay that way is through amazing
pub crawls like I was on a clown pub
crawl in Chicago where 85 men and women
dressed as clowns half of us took acid
which oh that won't snap your brain in
half yes it will
it really will and we hired a sober guy
to drive us to bars unannounced did not
tell any of the bars that 85 drunken
acid headed clowns were coming to their
establishments you can imagine the
carnage like we'd go into like old man
bars and the guys like slow night what
the hell
time to do shots just having a blast and
at one point we're leaving a Chili's
that I'm pretty sure we set on fire
yeah and we're halfway across Michigan
Avenue which is like eight lanes wide
right we're halfway across and there's a
cop in the squad car well we didn't know
a cop was in a squad car well we thought
the squad car was a dragon we were that
high it's a dragon oh it's asleep though
clowns go and we crossed the street and
we're halfway across and the cop gets
his loudspeaker never had a cop talked
to through a loudspeaker it's meant to
be heard over a riot right super loud
he's like hey hey and we stopped in the
middle of the street like did you hear
that tuberosum but we didn't just stop
we like pop-lock breakdance froze like
what what right so scared and we each
took on like a different casual pose
like a hive mind of drunk clowns what
time is it I have a newspaper I'm
walking a dog no you're not you're not
blending in you stupid forest of frozen
clowns and we're totally still and it's
dead silent it's a kind of silence
before a gunfight in the Old West like
all you can hear is tumbleweeds and wind
and the cop gets back in his loudspeaker
swear to God goes quit clowning around
son of a [ __ ] Oh hilarious cop you made
me pee my clown suit well done thank you
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you cannot happen PTO's that
Braunger yeah